all right good morning everyone so today
I'm really excited because we're about
to be done with complex analysis and
we're about to start getting into some
really really neat physical modeling of
interesting systems fluids elastics
quantum mechanics optics heat transfer
we're gonna be able to start solving
really really powerful problems now in
PDEs and advanced to OD ease using some
of the tools that we've learned in
complex analysis so I've almost taught
you everything I wanted to tell you
about complex analysis and I have two
more lectures and so during these two
lectures we basically have all of the
tools to start solving really really
complicated interesting integrals and we
also have the tools to start doing
things like analytically computing
inverse Laplace transforms and Fourier
transforms which are going to be really
really important for solving PDEs okay
I cooked up a code last night that I
wanted to show you because I think a lot
of what we're talking about with complex
functions can be a little bit kind of
abstract and you know it turns out you
can actually plot these complex
functions in MATLAB and visualize the
surfaces to see what things look like so
it's actually not as complicated as I've
been making it okay so we all remember
the mesh grid command hopefully from
last quarter so if I want to variables x
and y and I want an entire domain maybe
a rectangular domain and x and y from
negative 10 to 10 and X and negative 10
to 10 and Y I can use this mesh grid
command and I get this big array of X
and a big array of Y all the X values in
that 2d array all the Y values and what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
compute the logarithm of X plus iy ok so
I have a 10 by maybe a 20 by 20 patch in
the complex plane
and I'm gonna just take and compute the
logarithm the great thing about MATLAB
is that it can absolutely deal with
complex numbers it can do e to the
complex numbers log of complex numbers
not a problem and I'm gonna plot the
real imaginary and absolute values of
this thing okay any questions about this
code
all right let's plot this let me try
that again
and I'm gonna use some fancy commands
like face color in Terp edge color none
and face lighting Phong which is
obviously the best way to light a face
okay so this is what our real and
imaginary parts of our complex logarithm
look like so the top we have this nice
singularity that we talked about before
so this kind of goes down to negative
infinity at the origin that's what we
mean by a singularity this looks like a
black hole or blue hole and this is the
imaginary part of my complex logarithm
but what's wrong with this picture
exactly it can't handle more than it's
not going to give me infinite you know
an infinite vector of imaginary parts
that's going to give me the principal
value the you know zero actually
negative PI to PI is what MATLAB gives
me interesting so I'm only getting one
branch of my complex logarithm okay but
you do clearly see that if I started
doing an integral you know around a
circle at containing zero
I would pick up two pi in the imaginary
part of my log Z my real part I would
you know integrate to zero okay and
there's this weird thing that happens at
the point Z equals zero you see this
crazy cusp where it actually is kind of
not just infinite discrete values but it
has a continuum of values from you know
all along this vertical axis okay so the
last thing I want to do is to I thought
to myself how do I make that spiral
staircase plot in MATLAB okay and it's
actually a lot easier than I thought it
would be actually I thought this might
do it but it didn't so now what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to create another
mesh grid but I'm gonna create this in
polar coordinates okay I'm gonna have R
and theta or a mesh grid so my radius is
gonna go from point one to ten so it's
kind of a circle of radius 10 and my
theta is gonna go from 0 in increments
of 0.1 up to 20 which is like three
periods right that's about three two pi
two PI's okay I can create my x and y
and I can take and analytically expand
my log as log of the radius plus I times
theta because we know that that's
exactly true and now when I plot this I
get my awesome multi-tiered stare kind
of function here so this is a
visualization of three branches of our
complex logarithm
the coloring is just by height the
coloring means nothing and this is just
the imaginary part of the complex
logarithm okay so you can really
visualize these things you can create
plots one that I really like is to plot
instead of the imaginary part of Z I
like plotting the absolute value of Z
which looks really strange so this is
the absolute value of sorry absolute
value of log of Z if anyone has a 3d
printer and would like to print any one
of these for my desk I would be totally
cool with that
but it has these great kind of weird
cuss P features so it you can see that
it has the singularity the black hole
but it also has this kind of multivalued
weird branch point at Z equals zero this
multivalued thing so this is like an
especially weird version absolute value
or magnitude of log of Z sorry absolute
value of log of Z okay that's what I
wanted to show you in MATLAB any
questions before I shut it down
okay so today what I want to do is just
very very briefly summarize the things
we've learned and then use these to
start showing you how to solve really
really interesting and powerful
integrals so we've learned what types of
functions are or are not analytic and
I've asked you this every lecture and
I'm pretty sure you all know what they
are now we know that if we integrate an
analytic function over an analytic
domain over a closed curve then that
integral equals zero okay that's the
Koshi course ah theorem we know that if
we integrate a complex function and
there's some singularities in the middle
as long as I have my contour integral in
some analytic domain I can continuously
deform it any way I want within that
domain as long as I don't break the
curve and the most important formula we
learned is the Cauchy integral formula
this was just yesterday which is how do
I want to say this so the integral the
closed integral around a contour C of f
of zdz divided by z minus a is equal to
2pi i F of a and there's some conditions
that's if you know F is analytic in C
and this point a is inside C that's it
okay if I have an analytic function you
know somewhere inside my close contour C
and I have this point a which is inside
that contour I add the singularity and
this is what my integral equals this is
going to allow us to solve tons of
awesome integrals that we didn't think
we'd be able to solve okay now that
you've had some time to think about it
are there any general questions about
this Koshi integral formula
okay okay there's one more useful fact I
want to tell you and then we're gonna do
some examples so for the next two days
we're just gonna do examples okay
because I want you to actually have some
experience doing these crazy integrals
because I'm gonna ask you some of them
on exams so a final useful formula and
this formula is called the ml bound M L
bound so the idea is if I have some
function if if my function f is bounded
if the absolute value of f is bounded by
M meaning that the radius of f of Z is
less than M on my contour and if the
length of my contour my contour so the
integral over my contour of D s is equal
to L so I'm defining M is the bound of
my function on a contour the biggest
value that it reaches on the contour and
L is just the length of the contour then
the absolute value of the contour
integral of f of Z DZ is less than or
equal to M times L this actually makes
perfect sense I'll draw a picture this
is like extremely intuitive why this is
true if you could explain what a complex
integral was to a five-year-old they
would probably believe this after you
draw the picture so
the basic idea is that I have some
contour C and it has length L okay so
what I'm gonna do is I'm essentially
this contour can have singularities in
it
okay this integral might not equal zero
it might equal some crazy stuff there
might be a ton of singularities inside
of here okay we're not getting the exact
answer of what this integral equals
we're just getting a bound on how big
the integral could possibly be and so
the idea is this is like a worst case
scenario bound on what the integral of f
could possibly be okay this is a worst
case scenario so f has a bunch of values
right there's some F value here and here
and here and here my function has values
all along the circle and one of those
values is going to be larger than all of
the other ones right unless there's a
singularity in which case that would be
like infinite but one of these function
values is going to be larger in
magnitude than all of the other ones
okay that's M that's the largest
function value the absolute value of f
now imagine in the worst case scenario
the entire function along the entire
contour was equal to that very large
value M okay so my entire function is
just let's see if I can draw this so in
the complex plane I have my you know my
contour and I have some function on this
circle which is you know it's going
around the circle looks like a ring or
like a crown or something this is the
largest value M and what we're assuming
is how big would this integral be if the
entire function on this entire integral
was equal to M okay and that's exactly
equal to M times L if my
higher function was a constant equal to
em and I integrated em over my contour i
would get M times L so that's the
biggest this integral could possibly be
is if F was equal to its largest value
on the entire contour for any other
possible F these values might be smaller
than M or some of them might be positive
and others might be negative and they'll
cancel and so this integral is always
going to be less than M times L less
than or equal it could be equal if I
have a really boring constant function
equal to M okay questions about this I
see some unease
[Applause]
why are we interested in doing this why
are we interested in doing this that's a
great question so yeah really really
good question so what we're gonna do so
this is a good segue into the next
portion let's say that I have some
really nasty integral that I want to
perform let's say that I have I have my
complex plane and I have some function
that has some singularities okay some
function f of Z has these singularities
and let's say that my boss tells me I
need this integral here okay I need the
integral from minus infinity to infinity
of f of X DX it's a really nasty
integral I didn't tell you what f of X
is but it's nasty okay so if your boss
wants this often what you can do is you
can create a big circle enclosing those
two poles so this is a circle of radius
R okay so this this is C 1 this is C R
and the whole contour is C so the
integral around this entire contour of f
of zdz is equal to the thing I want I
have to take the limit as R goes to
infinity okay it's the thing I want plus
this big huge integral around this very
large radius contour CR ok let's let's
take a step back I'm trying to solve
this real valued integral from negative
infinity to infinity ok I need to do
that sometimes what I can do is I can
take and create a closed contour C by
making this big radius R loop and
connecting and taking the limit as that
radius grows too and
and as I do that I can break this
contour up into the part I want which is
a real-valued integral along the x-axis
Plus this integral around this really
big circle R okay now I just took your
question of why we're doing this and I
pushed it to another question why does
my boss want this but just take my word
for now that we actually do want to
solve integrals occasionally and
sometimes they're nasty and so we can
use the ML bound to show that this term
goes to zero now that doesn't always
that's not always true but for lots of
functions as I increase the radius the
function gets smaller faster than the
radius gets larger and so M times L will
limit to zero so I this is a very very
powerful theorem I can make this term
zero sometimes and so I get this real
valued integral that I want is equal to
a complex valued integral with a few
simple poles inside and just last
lecture we realized how to like we found
out how to solve this integral using the
Cauchy integral formula okay so I can
solve my real valued nasty integrals
using the Cauchy integral formula that's
that's my next example
okay so we'll actually do this for up f
of X that I named okay any more
questions about the ML bounds before we
go on maybe I'll just do a really simple
real valued example let's say that I
have the integral of x squared from 0 to
1
integral from 0 to 1 of x squared DX is
equal to X cubed over 3 evaluated at 1
and 0 is just 1/3 right simple the area
under this curve is 1/3 now let's try
the ML bound what is the length of this
curve in X I'm integrating over just one
right if I integrated l equals integral
from 0 to 1 of D X which is just 1 my
length of the curve is 1 what's the
maximum value of x squared on that
interval 1 so M is equal to 1 and this
integral of course is less than or equal
to 1 times 1 M times L that makes sense
right like the worst case bound for this
integral is if the whole function was
equal to its biggest value on the whole
domain in which case the area would be
equal to M times L which is 1 this is
just exactly what we're doing here in
the complex plane we've just done it
using you know a fancy contour integral
and a complex valued function same deal
okay let me just color code this M times
L equals 1 and it's this green area here
ok all right think about this it's not
the most you know we're not going to use
ml a ton but you should feel comfortable
with using it after we do a couple of
examples okay
I'm gonna do a simple example of the
Koshi integral formula before we try to
tackle this really hard problem okay so
the reason we might want to solve some
of these nasty integrals are for example
to do inverse Laplace transforms fourier
transforms every once in a while there
is a real integral that you really do
want to solve and it's nice to know how
to solve it okay so this is a simple
example to get us started and this is a
simple example of the Cauchy integral
formula okay so let's say that my
function f of Z is equal to 1 over Z
squared minus 3 Z plus 2 ok this is my
function and I'm going to be able to
factor this so it's 1 over Z minus 1
times Z minus 2 so how many Poles does
this function have and where are they at
two poles at one and two okay so my
complex plane I have two poles at 1 and
at 2 and we're going to quickly solve a
bunch of rapid-fire contour integrals of
this function over different contours so
first we're gonna solve it over c1 over
c2 over C 3 and over c4 okay this is
just a review of stuff we've already
learned from the last lecture
okay so let's make a couple of important
remarks so first note that I'm going to
create a new function called G of Z so G
of Z equals 1 over Z minus 2 G 1 ah
let's call this G 2 is analytic near Z
equals 1 and our other function G 1
which is just 1 over Z 1 Z minus 1 is
analytic near Z equals 2 so I'm
decomposing my function into you know G
1 times G 2 and G 1 is analytic near my
second pole and my second function is
analytic near my first pole ok which
means I can apply Koshi integral formula
so let's try integral around C 1 of F of
Z f of zdz
ok that's just equal to G 2
/ Z minus 1 DZ let me write it out long
ways this is the contour integral around
C 1 of 1 over Z minus 2 times DZ over Z
minus 1 remember our Koshi integral
formula we have this integral of f of Z
over Z minus a DZ equals 2 pi I a ok so
so we're just doing this little contour
integral here over one pole this is my
function right this is the thing I'm
integrating this is f of Z this part is
analytic at my pole right so this is
equal to 2 pi I times this evaluated at
Z equals 1 times you know g2 evaluated
at this thing here my function my
analytic function evaluated at my pole
here is just 1 over Z minus 2 evaluated
at Z equals 1 evaluated at the pole is
this making sense or is this how many is
this making sense how many would like me
to say this one more time more clearly
and slowly ok a few of you so let me
just try this one more time ok I'm
taking this contour integral around a
single pole of this function this
function right here this is the function
I'm integrating around that pole ok
now this function we can we can cast it
into the Koshi integral formula form if
we want by saying that this is my
analytic function f of Z this is
analytic near Z equals one and this is
my 1 over Z minus a ok so this part is
analytic around this pole and this other
part this 1 over Z minus a I equals 1
and so the solution to this integral
using Koshi integral formula is 2 pi i
times this function f evaluated at this
pole a which is 1 over 1 minus 2 so we
get 2 pi i times 1 over 1 minus 2 is
just minus 2 pi i okay if this is still
confusing i'm gonna post my notes online
you can kind of go over this again just
try to think about how you can look at
this contour integral in terms of the
Koshi integral formula and it should
make sense ok so that's my integral of
contour 1 it's equal to minus 2 pi i
simple similarly if I take my contour
integral around contour 2 DZ it's the
same thing except now it's integral of C
to my analytic part now is 1 over Z
minus 1 like this is the part of the
function that's analytic at my pole Z
equals 2 times DZ over Z minus 2 and so
this equals 2 pi I times my analytic
part evaluate it at my pole so 1 over Z
minus 1 evaluated at Z equals 2 that's
just F of a
and that equals two pi I like positive 2
pi there's a little unfortunate that I
chose the same function f here and here
this is just a dummy function that's
analytic not the same as this F okay so
what's the contour integral around C 3
equal ok how many of you think it is
positive negative zero okay why would it
be equal to zero basically the right
idea so if I have these two poles and I
have some big contour integral C 3 then
I can shrink that contour integral down
to something that's basically a full
loop around here a full loop around here
and then these two segments that cut
cancel each other out so I basically
have you know integral of C 1 plus
integral of C 2 is equal to integral of
C 3 and because one's plus and ones -
they cancel out it's just a coincidence
for this problem that they cancel out to
0 okay so being familiar with how you
can do this kind of mapping and surgery
of these contour integrals is super
super important knowing that you can
take your contour integrals and deform
them as long as you're deforming them
inside of an analytic read region that's
probably the most I mean that that's
actually the most useful like trick in
solving these these integrals is being
able to deform your contour to somewhere
that your integral becomes simpler and
here this is a lot simpler right my plus
and minus parts cancel and I just get c1
plus c2 and what's the integral of c4
zero right because the function is
analytic in this region even though it's
got singularities over here it's smooth
over here okay not as simple of a
problem as I thought okay so now we're
gonna get back to so now we're going to
get back to this idea here which
motivated this ml bound okay so we're
gonna take some function f of X that we
want to integrate from minus infinity to
infinity and the way we're gonna do that
is we're going to first integrate this
big closed contour which we can do using
Koshi integral formula and we're going
to show that the radial part is equal to
0 so my Koshi integral formula is going
to equal my real part of this integral
ok I'm just gonna go through this from
scratch on a concrete example and the
only way to get better at this is to
practice so when I was studying for
qualifying exams we would get together
in groups and do dozens of these
integrals we would just take a book and
take all of the nasty integrals you're
supposed to be able to solve with Koshi
integral formula and try them out and
you get really good at applying the
techniques and simplifying the problems
when you actually do some of them and I
can show you what the major tools are
but I can't get you good at using them
until you actually start using them ok
okay so the problem we're going to solve
this example is slightly more difficult
so we're going to integrate a function
from minus infinity to infinity and that
function is DX over X to the fourth plus
a to the fourth okay does anybody know
of a way to integrate this using
calculus
probably possible but I forgot okay and
it's also interesting to note that this
is equal to two times the integral from
zero to infinity of the same thing
because this is an even function so you
could also solve integrals from zero to
plus infinity just by because it's
symmetric for positive and negative x
okay so we're gonna do this trick we
talked about by creating a complex
contour integral in the complex plane so
we're gonna turn into a contour integral
problem Khan tor integral and it looks
almost exactly like what I just showed
you I'm just going to go through the
steps really carefully and really slowly
so I'm gonna take this function this
contour C 1 plus C R C 1 plus C R and
I'm going to call that C that's my
contour it's a closed contour and when I
take the limit as R goes to infinity of
the integral of C 1 of DX over X to the
4th plus a to the 4th that clearly
equals this thing that I'm trying to
solve should probably put this is minus
R to R and this is radius R ok so I have
this big radius R 1/2 circle that I'm
integrating around and the flat part of
it
if I took the limit as R goes to
infinity would be the thing I actually
want okay
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
turn this into a function of a complex
variable Z which is fine if I took that
function and I integrated it on the real
part it would still be real valued so
I'm going to say I want the contour
integral around C of DZ over Z to the
fourth plus a to the fourth right I just
took this function in every place I saw
an X I just put a Z in and if I
integrate this on the real axis these
are all real again okay
this equals and I take the limit as R
goes to infinity this equals the thing I
want I plus the limit as R goes to
infinity of this radial contour integral
of DZ over Z to the fourth plus a to the
fourth I'm just this is a common trick
I'm making stuff up right now I
basically have this integral I want and
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna close
the loop I'm Glam that I can solve this
part so we can solve this using the
Cauchy integral formula okay I'll do
that in a minute and I'm going to set
this I'm going to show that this is
equal to 0 by ML bounds okay which would
you like to see first would you like me
to Excel this nasty contour integral
using Koshi integral formula or show
that this big radial part is equal to 0
the ML bound part first okay good this
is just accounting we're just doing
accounting these things have to add up
ok and if this one's equal to 0 then I
equals this ok so how do we prove that
this is equal to 0 by ML bounds
okay so what's the length of this big CR
PI R okay L equals PI R right length of
contour not the counter the contour and
now what I need to figure out is what is
an upper bound M on my function on this
entire contour but what does this look
like my function what does my function
gonna look like for big R it's gonna
look a lot like one over R to the fourth
right Z to the fourth has a real part of
R to the fourth not a real part of an
absolute value a magnitude of R to the
fourth so this thing M equals the
maximum value of all of the Z's on my
contour of 1 over Z to the fourth plus a
to the fourth and this is always smaller
than or equal to 1 over R to the fourth
like if I take 1 divided by R to the
fourth plus 5 it's always less than 1
over R to the fourth basically what
we're doing but in the complex plane
so this function is always less than or
equal to 1 over R to the fourth and so
if R gets really really big my function
gets absolutely minuscule and my
function gets smaller faster than my
curve gets longer okay so this the size
of the big radius part of my contour
integral is less than or equal to
pi R over R to the fourth so the
contribution from this integral is less
than PI over R cubed and what am i doing
- r I'm taking R to infinity so this
term goes to zero it's just a simple way
of saying that the function value on
this curve is so small that as I make
that curve you know infinite in size
even though the length of that curve is
also infinite my function gets
infinitesimally smaller faster and so it
integrates up to zero as R goes to
infinity this is why we use the ML
bounds because we've just made this part
here equal to zero okay this is step one
okay step one step two is actually
finding what I equals now now we know
that I equals this contour integral and
I claim that we actually have the tools
to do that now it just lost my papers
all right all right these problems are
nasty
I wouldn't recommend like stressing too
much about all of the little details
what I really want you to know is the
big picture of how to solve these things
and I want you to have the experience to
solve them if you have to so just get
good enough that you know the the basic
ideas okay so now we're trying to solve
the left function using Koshi integral
formula okay so step two we need to
actually compute this contour integral
of DZ divided by Z 2
fourth plus a to the fourth now how can
I solve this using the Cauchy integral
formula is my function analytic on and
inside this bread contour or maybe asked
another way does this function have any
singularities okay some of you think yes
it has singularities some of you think
no it does not have singularities okay
it does in fact have singularities
because there are roots of this equation
okay
so my function you know f of Z equals
one over Z to the fourth plus a to the
fourth has four singularities okay
it has singularities at Z to the fourth
equals minus a to the fourth and we can
take the fourth root of minus a to the
fourth so Z equals a times the fourth
root of negative one and we know that we
can compute the fourth root of negative
one we have a formula to do that now
okay so these singularities have radius
a and they're in the directions of the
four roots of negative one so I'm just
going to draw those there's one here
here here and here
we call this a 1 a 2 a 3 a 4 ok and if I
really wanted to write these out which I
don't particularly but I have to they
are plus or minus a plus or minus I a
divided by square root of 2 these are
the singularities of my function my
function is singular and blows up to
infinity at these four points and Z
okay so let me ask you again does this
big red contour integral of my function
equal zero probably not because I've got
singularities inside I can't just
offhand say that it equals zero by coach
Egor saw because it's not analytic in
side C okay so now what are my
techniques for actually finding what
this contour integral equals sorry yeah
exactly I can say that f of z equals
this isn't getting just nasty or nastier
I have Z minus a 1 times Z minus a 2
times z minus a 3 times Z minus a 4
that's F okay now if i zoom in remember
we can always kind of rewrite this
contour as this funny thing here
okay so I can I'm basically just trying
to sum up the contour integral around
this pole and the contour integral are
on this pole that we can definitely do
so let's start with you know this
contour integral around a 1 and this
contour integral around a 2 so my
contour integral around a 1 what part of
this function is analytic near a 1
everything except for that this part of
the function is analytic at a 1 ok so by
Koshi integral formula I'm going to
write this down I'm going to say this is
equal to you know DZ over Z minus a 2
times Z minus a 3 times Z minus a 4
times 1 over Z minus a 1 so this is the
analytic part near a 1 and this is my
singularity okay so what does Koshi
integral formula tell me that this
integral equals good 2 pi x times this
analytic part where i plug in a 1 for
all of the Z's it's actually not
terrible like I'm not thrilled about
what comes next but this parts not bad
so this is you know 1 over a 1 minus a 2
times a 1 minus a 3 times a 1 minus a 4
ok that's the integral around that first
green circle okay walk me through the
second green circle it's basically the
same ok I want to hear from you all how
do I do the second green circle integral
of C around a 2
okay DZ and what do I want on this left
side right I want the analytic part
which is Z minus a 1 it's everything but
the pole does u minus a 1 times u minus
a 3 times Z minus a 4 times my
singularity 1 minus Z minus 1 over Z
minus a 1 and again exact same thing
it's 2 pi I times my analytic part
evaluated at my pole Koshu is a genius
this is so much easier 2 pi times now
this is a 2 minus a 1 a 2 minus a 3 a 2
minus a 4 all under one okay we can plug
in these numbers a 1 a 2 a 3 and a 4 we
actually know them so I can plug these
all in it sounds horrible I'm not going
to do it I'll just tell you what it is I
did it this morning you get so the
integral of C 1 plus the integral of C
a2 equals PI over root 2a cubed and this
is equal to this big contour integral
which is equal to I my real valued
integral from negative infinity to
infinity
this is I you can actually code this up
in MATLAB make a bunch of little D X's
and integrate out sufficiently far and
I'm assuming it'll converge to something
a lot like this so test that out that's
something you can do like right when you
go home first thing you do it'll be
awesome ok that's everything I want to
tell you today ok
next lecture we'll do Laplace transforms
[Music]
you